it's time to start thinking about
quarterbacks how do quarterbacks look
because you know they always look good
when you're in the best shape of your
life
or the best in shapeness of your life
you always look good in practice
let's begin with the chicago bears as
they try to resurrect mitchell trubisky
second overall pick
in the 2017 draft here is
some of the chatter coming out of
chicago as it relates to
mitchell trubisky both from his head
coach and from
trubisky himself and from one of the
players to whom trubisky may be throwing
the football
he's in a place right now mentally that
i really just feel like is really good
you know
this is now going to the third year with
me and me being able to learn who he is
i like where he's at he actually looks
like a whole new player this year man
it's
it's just i just see it in his eyes he
shouldn't ever date man he he's got that
fire on him so
i feel like he's he's been a more leader
you know last year i didn't feel like he
would
he was that guy but this year i feel
like he's taking over
he he wants everybody to know he he's
that guy and we can come to him when we
need someone
and he's doing that he's doing a hell of
a job of it
kind of a compliment from cordero
patterson yeah it was
yeah you're kind of right kind of an
insult yeah last year he wasn't that guy
this year he is that guy and it's easy
to be that guy when you're not playing
games the question is
are you going to be that guy during the
weekend and week out grind when you hit
adversity in football season
you feel like you've had a bad game
you're down in the dumps
you're trying to find a way to get
yourself going again you're
you're having self-doubt in yourself as
you would say
uh i i just i i look i don't exp if if a
guy doesn't look great at this stage of
the season in
camp practicing without the opportunity
of being hit
if he doesn't look great now he's never
gonna look great chris they all have to
look great now yeah well
you're right about that you should be
looking pretty good you know because
yeah it hasn't got
you know too in-depth as far as the
defenses that are being thrown at you
and things like that but you know you're
right too the ultimate
test will be how do you react to those
live bullets if you are the starting
quarterback there in chicago
but like even that you know we're going
to read between the tea leaves right i
mean
there's some things there to take away
where i go yeah
cordero patterson obviously is referring
to last year
this guy did not give an aura of
confidence or
make you feel like whoa he's got it all
down here in this offense and he's
feeling good and
we can just you know jump on his back
and he'll carry us
but when you hear mentally you know in a
good place like nagi is saying
and you could see it in his eyes and a
whole different person
you know that to me just in quarterback
talk
it shows me that probably a guy that has
a
true understanding of the offense now
yeah it's his third year in the nfl
and he's used to nfl life and what it
takes to get ready
but you know again that you know he's
been in two different systems in a very
short time in his career and last year
was only a second year in the matinee
system he certainly regressed
but when i hear like different look in
the eye and better place
mentally that to me shows a guy that's
stopped thinking
you know he's breaking the huddle now
and welcoming
questions like oh no hey you line up
here hey be ready for this right given
all those kind of clues where last year
he was probably like breaking the huddle
and not looking at anybody because he
was like please don't ask me a question
i'm not sure what the hell i'm supposed
to do yet you know so
there is that and that confidence that
core daryl patterson talks about in your
eyes
you know he could probably see man this
guy's telling the play he's barking it
out
where there used to be this pause of him
like you know wait what's going on
here what do i have to do here hey i'm
talking to you guys but i'm also
thinking of my own brain and the players
aren't fooled by that stuff
that makes sense couple of things okay
it does make sense first of all i want
to say this because there are people who
are now
paying attention at home for the next
page in the book of simsism
and i do have to say when you said let's
read between the tea leaves
that you were reading off of the
document i don't know who we blame
for printing in it's a self-aware joke
right
all right because i say it all the time
yes i say it
i do i've missed it it's reading between
the lines and reading the tea leaves
it's a little indeed
it's a little more in depth than your
normal you know it's like
it's like self-scouting myself which and
it's a thing the first time someone's
watching
and hopefully every day there is someone
who's watching for the first time
they may wonder what the hell was going
on i have missed
or forgotten reading between the tea
leaves
for that yeah i don't think you're an
avid listener of my podcast either so i
i mean i understand i'm not
avid no i'm not uh only when i'm on it
is when i listen to it and even then
it's 50
of the time um i i i
as true trubisky you know here's the
thing it went so well
in nagi's first year and they got to the
playoffs they went 12 and 4.
last year was the year that i think
maybe nagi wanted to maybe open up more
of the playbook and throw
right whiskey a little more into it and
maybe that's when he got overwhelmed by
it all
like maybe that first year i'm just
gonna do the things that i know this kid
can do
second year i'm going to challenge him
i'm going to pull him out of the comfort
zone i'm going to try to make him into a
guy who fits this offense
not my offense into something that fits
him and maybe that's when it went off
the rails
i don't know yeah but you know obviously
matt neggie's gotten to the point where
he's exasperated with mitchell trubisky
and he
wants someone who can run that offense
and that's why nick foles is there
and for now trubisky responding to the
challenge by
stepping up and exuding the confidence
and doing the things and saying the
things he needs to do
the question is like you said when it's
time to play in a real game
if it is trubisky on the field or if it
is nick foles or if they both get
opportunities
how will trubisky react when he
encounters
that adversity and how will falls play
you know
foles has been the backup yep
he's been the starter he's been and i
think this is the first time
maybe since early in his career when it
was him
and it was mike vick and we weren't
really sure
who the guy was in philly until one guy
took it and ran with it and that was
foals frankly
uh this is kind of the first time foles
has been in that mode it's been eight
years
where we're not really sure who the guy
is but we don't know how foals are going
to play when he's the unquestioned
starter
it ain't so good when he's the backup
it's pretty damn good yeah right it's
kind of even
you know maybe maybe foals ends up maybe
this is all a waste of time
maybe trubisky is going to still be on
the bench because
it also matters how falls looks and what
foals does and whether foals can run
away with the job well
you hear and you know i've seen a few
things where people say
foals has been impressive i mean the one
thing i can i think we can count on from
foals here
is he's not gonna blink uh he's not
affected by this you know the one thing
we know about him is he's
he's pretty much the same guy oh hey
we're down by seven in the super bowl
we're up by seven in the super bowl
we're up by 30 in the nfc championship
game
he's pretty even keel and doesn't seem
to be affected by much
and you know i i've had people push back
on me on my podcast sometimes ago
because i go you know nick foles is
going to know this offense every bit as
you know well as trubisky and people
yeah what do you mean trubisky this is
the second year in the system
yeah but nick foles has been with andy
reid and been with doug peterson this is
the same offense
it's going to be almost the same
verbiage he's going to understand all
the same rules and all that so
he is not going to be in a mentally
flustered place
like you would for most free agent
quarterbacks who are coming in like
maybe a brady who's trying to learn a
language still and
you know figuring out wait you know this
meant go route in new england
now this means go route here in tampa
bay all of those things you know there's
going to be comfort level
there with nick foles so i expect him to
be the consistent one
you know trubisky he he's got some
special qualities about him to where he
could be the guy that
makes the more you know you know
eye-popping plays
runs big throws things like that
certainly
but the issue is you know he
can be very inconsistent with
decision-making and throwing
and that's what i think we're hearing so
far just as out of that bearish camp is
that seems to have improved if i was
just taking anything away from those
comments we heard yesterday or anything
and
that'll be interesting we'll we'll see
where it goes but yeah the offense
has to take the next step the offense i
do believe
was probably i know was held back a
little bit by trubisky last year
certainly i think you explained it right
it was year two
they wanted to expand and because year
one they kind of just like you said kept
it basic
let's let trubisky scramble a few times
and we got this great defense
well year two people caught on to some
of that basic stuff and you want to
expand but i think it was overwhelming
to trubisky
and it caused some moments of yeah some
some below average play
remember the comment in the monday night
game right early oh season
that was it monday or sunday that they
can't they that was his
that was his first year that was two
years ago that was that was that was
that but right but that was
2018. right that that but that that
confirms
that they went training wheels with him
in 2018 week two monday night
2018 they were going easy they were
going basic
and it worked it worked and then last
year it didn't work because they were
going
less basic the training wheels came off
and the wheels came off after the
training wheels came off
here's something that i'm still going to
keep an eye on
because in this craziest of seasons with
everything being upside down
and no preseason to put guys out there
and see how they play
i am expecting that there will be not
just
at the quarterback position but across
the board i think we're going to see
more rotation of guys in we're going to
have more guys getting live reps you're
not going to have your depth chart set
in stone
week one because you haven't had a
chance to see how guys look
and why why would you go blindly with
the first stringer from last year when
there may be a new guy
who hasn't had a chance to prove himself
in the preseason you treat september as
a quasi pre-season
and also and you justify it by saying
hey you never know when a guy is going
to be on the covet 19 list we got to
have everybody ready to play
we got to have everybody ready to go in
the event that someone
test positive and isn't available and
you extend that to the quarterback
position as well
because how can you really tell who your
best guy is for the balance of the
season
unless you find a way to get both of
them on the field early and what's wrong
with that chris i know that
you know you got you need that one guy
who's the leader and the platoon systems
never really worked and steve spurrier
tried and it was a disaster in
washington
but i feel like this may be the year to
consider something like that if you
don't have a settled and clear-cut
number one quarterback
i i don't disagree with you i don't
think it's as crazy as
you know i would push back in years past
you know this could be one of those
scenarios where
yeah you got two guys that was very
close in training camp hey
you know true bit let's just say
trubisky is the starter they decide to
go with trubisky
let's say they win week one right mike
but it's it's ugly it's not a good
offensive
game you know game for the quarterback
or the offense in general but they win
16 to 13. would i sit there and go
okay now it's week two trubisky starts
again but the same thing
game starts off it's shaky you know
they're down
six to three what i think it's crazy to
go oh okay
they're putting nick foles in to kind of
see what he's got can he jump start the
offense can they do something around him
schematically that makes more sense for
their team
all of those to tinker with it in this
type of scenario
i think it is more realistic than years
past you're right but
but this is one gr one team i think or
there's not a lot of teams that fit
this conversation the bears are you know
in a special place here
right and and look the platoon system
has in one specific situation
worked although it wasn't used for long
do you remember 2007
arizona cardinals yeah matliner was the
starter
right anytime they'd fall behind by
seven points
kurt warner got put onto the field and
he would
pull the bacon out of the fire and even
things up and then liner would come back
and then they'd fall behind and then
warner would come back in and then
they'd get back in the game and then
line it would go and it continued and
liner didn't like it
until he broke a collarbone and it was
kurt warner all the time and that was
that for matt leinart
but you know i i j you know we hear all
the time when there's a quarterback
injured
they try to keep it all close to the
vest because you want the defense to
have to prepare for both gosh well use
both guys and then they have to prepare
for both guys
they're going to waste time preparing
for both guys they're not wasting it
because they need to
dilute their preparation for one because
they have to prepare for the other
because they're going to see both at
some point
i just i think this year it's something
that
in the cities that do not have a clear
cut number one it's something that you
can use
as a weapon it's something you can use
strategically to make your team better
if you can get your quarterbacks to buy
into it chris well yeah i you know i
don't know i i mean
there's a there's a lot there there
really is i mean the platoon system is
different to me than
hey you know we started one guy
hey it's week two like i just explained
we're still struggling on offense we're
gonna put another guy in
and see if he can be i'm saying use them
in the same i know you are same game
i know you are you know not not if one
guy struggles no
i know we are using both we are
even if the even if the first guy is 10
for 10
we're gonna give the other guys some
reps and see through that process
which guy is going to be our our starter
eventually that's what i'm saying
treat it like kind of like the priest
they could i mean they could do that
certainly i mean i i don't think it's
crazy uh now
you know there's other issues with this
offense too but
you know again i don't think that's
always going to lead itself a true
platoon system quarterback is so
hard to play and if you're in one series
out another series in two series out two
series
i did this my sophomore year early on
with major applewhite of texas
it was the dumbest crap ever you know
there's parts of me that looks back at
it now and just said you know coach the
hell with it just let him play
and when he gets hurt i'll come in and
we'll see where it goes from there
because there was days mike where this
is where
there was games where i was the hot
quarterback i was the hot hand
but he had been there and they trusted
him and it was a big moment and even
though i had outplayed him that day
here we were he was going to go in and
you know that that bothered me it still
bothers me as you could tell
but i don't know if it's best for the
team i don't know if it's always best
for the offense
uh and it's hard to formulate you know
game
plans and a way to attack you know the
most
effective way when you're playing
different types of quarterbacks i hear
what you're saying it gives them
different wrinkles different looks
uh but i'm not so sure that's the best
thing for a team especially where if i'm
the bears
i want to play through my defense i want
to run the ball maybe a little bit this
year
that'll help the quarterback and set the
tone that way and play action passes off
of it and do that
um you know i'm never in favor of
platooning the quarterback that's one
position where it just it's
it's it's tough for me to say i like
that quick story when i was in college a
very long time ago obviously was not on
the football team it was at carnegie
mellon they had
two entire offenses and
one would play as long as they scored
and if they punted or had a turnover the
other entire offense went in the
ultimate
meritocracy two separate offenses
and as long as you keep having success
you keep playing i can't remember if the
team was any good but i'll never forget
that experiment and uh you know maybe
you could do something like that at the
quarterback position put one guy in as
long as you score points
you're the guy well you don't the other
guy gets a chance i'll say this much
you know first off we're talking
quarterback quarterback quarterback
quarterback and i owed also low like you
know and again we know maybe trubisky
was a big part of
you know holding back matt nagy and his
offense and everything like that but
this is we're gonna see
this year because that offense has to
grow to help the quarterbacks i know
that
you know and if trebrisky's the one
holding you back and you can't grow it
to that you know point
then damn don't play him nick foles has
got to be the player so
that is going to be a big issue but the
offense itself last year was
underwhelming uh predictable you know
you heard us talk about yesterday with
the dallas cowboys
you know i never understood what the
bears were trying to do
as a game plan like i never looked at a
game film and went oh
i get it they're trying to run and
attack this side and you know they got a
weakness here in the secondary they're
trying to
take okay that makes sense oh yeah they
got a lot of cool plays to attack that
no it seemed like it was just like hey
here let's spin the rolodex oh play 44.
hey here mitch play 44.
hey next play oh i don't know well it's
play 77 let's go to play 77.
okay cool great cool play you know
there's got to be something more to that
let alone their offensive line stunk
and their run game stunk so you know all
those things got to get cleaned up
too if we want this quarterback thing to
work and
the other thing too mike just to throw
it on there to add to your
you know quarterback wrinkle or whatever
if you do have nick foles as a starter
trubisky can be that slash type
quarterback if you wanted to do it
you know yeah throw it throw him a
screen pass you know give him a toss
quarterback pass you know things like
that i mean he is that type of athlete
that
certainly wouldn't be at a place in that
certain situation to give them a
schematical advantage you're talking
about he didn't run as much last year as
as in 2018
but he was dangerous i remember that
scenario against the vikings he was
running circles around right
minnesota defense until he got injured
in that game patriots game remember he
had some great scrambles that year
uh he hurt his shoulder early last year
and i wonder if that also
affected his willingness to want to run
and scramble too
the the handwriting though is on the
wall for trubisky when they don't pick
up the fifth year option when they bring
in
foals it's clear that they are
disenchanted
with trubisky it's on him now to get the
team
that's right it's mine hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports